una acción inminente es lo que ha
planteado el actual jefe interino de la
policía de ottawa para acabar con las
protestas y bloqueos que paralizan a la
capital desde hace semanas en los
últimos días nos hemos comunicado
directamente con los manifestantes
ilegales les hemos dicho que deben
marcharse y les hemos advertido de las
consecuencias de desobedecer estas
normas en las calles de ottawa la
policía sigue aumentando la presión
contra los manifestantes repartiendo
notificaciones de advertencias sobre
severas penalidades si no se levantan
los bloqueos algunos manifestantes se
mantienen desafiantes
nos están entregando esta carta
indicándonos que hay una orden de la
policía para retirarnos esto es lo que
hacemos con ella
alrededor de 400 vehículos siguen
obstaculizando el y de tránsito ante el
parlamento el primer ministro canadiense
de hechos tintado explicó por qué
solicitó poderes de emergencia para
ponerle fin a las protestas
y los bloqueos y las ocupaciones son
ilegales son una amenaza para nuestra
economía y nuestra relación con los
socios comerciales son una amenaza para
las cadenas de suministro y la
disponibilidad de bienes esenciales como
alimentos y medicinas y son una amenaza
para la seguridad pública de favor
excepto el autodenominado convoy de la
libertad inició sus manifestaciones el
28 de enero en rechazo a la medida
gubernamental que exigía a los
camioneros tener el esquema completo de
vacunación contra el kobe 19 para cruzar
la frontera con eeuu sin embargo las
protestas se extendieron a otros
reclamos que incluyen todas las
restricciones impuestas por la pandemia
además de inconformidades hacia el
gobierno